you as you say your book starts with
this image of your mother reassuring you
um well failing to reassure you
um about death and I suppose in one way
I suppose saying it's not going to be
painful or frightening in some way it's
going to be gentle so I guess it brings
up the question
um of finitude which we were talking
about earlier
um and to what extent is
um would you call it a fear in a culture
or your fear or your fear which you see
occurring more widely which is of One's
Own Consciousness ending of of life
being finite how much of that plays into
your desire for God as
something that stops your own finitude
now I think that that for me that's key
and it's I mean I I mentioned in the
book something that atheists say uh I
think I'd quote Bertrand Russell uh and
Dawkins has said the same thing uh
Burton Russell said quite famously that
he was scorn uh to the idea of shivering
his own Oblivion yeah he's scornful
about the idea that you should be
frightened of Oblivion uh now there's
two things going on there number one is
again this atheist machismo uh it's like
you know well you know all these fairy
tales that people need to make up in
order to comfort themselves from the
ideas of whatever they're frightened of
principally death but all sorts of
things they're frightened of I the great
atheist need have no need of this I
don't believe that I think that's a pose
that a lot of atheists take in order to
feel kind of grown up and proper and big
uh but there's uh somebody else going on
there which is I think Dawkins has said
a similar thing but not quite you're not
quite as lofty away as Russell all which
is that why should you be frightened of
death because you won't know you're dead
and that seems very logical but it's
deeply for me inhuman because you're
only saying that from the point of view
of life and from the point of view of
life I promise you life seems a lot
better it really does like I I
like you know some people in here might
think well I I find life so difficult or
whatever that I find idea of nothingness
sort of more attractive but I think
that's unlikely I think that one of the
things about the book is it's I mean I
was born in Ipswich so
well
when my mum was talking to me I was
living in dollies Hill in 1970
three so I can tell you that as I say in
the book was a kind of death but I I
think the book is powered and I quote
John Updike quite a lot of them John who
is my favorite writer and who was a
Christian and deeply believed in God but
I think what I share with Updike uh
Updike had an almost hysterical but
obviously written attachment to life
like he was so like he a late book by
Updike he's called terrorist it's like a
lot of Updike books it's not that good
but what it's about it's about as a
suicide bomber and you might ask why is
John up like writing about a suicide
bomber I think it's because he got old
and he thought I need to write about
someone who is in love in the way that I
am with life with death I need to
somehow manage the idea of death and
create the love that I feel for Life
throughout death he calls uh life this
complex interval of Light which I think
is so beautiful and I think that
that's you know the book if it has a
sort of positive energy uh because it
might sound a bit deadly the way that
we're talking about it but the positive
energy is it is that it's a deep
commitment and love of whatever life may
hold even though life holds lots of
things it's still for me better than
Oblivion and I think that exists deeply
in all of us even if we might buy into
what I think is like a religious thing
of well there's a sort of serenity
infinitude
can I just come because I think that the
that's the idea of an interval of light
um it is it's fascinating it actually
reminds me of the venerable bead the
kind of great early British Theologian
who I think tells the story of of a
sparrow flying into the whole feasting
Hall
through one window and out the other and
he says that's an image of life you know
this brief moment where from the cold
and the dark you'll you're briefly in
this place of Noise music set laughter
and light and then out again
um but but it seems to me that part of
the
um
the conditions for being able to
celebrate and enjoy that interval is
that it's finite so there's a there's a
curious way in which death is the
necessary bookend
to all the good things that one enjoys
and a healthy this is true for anyone
whether religious or not that kind of
healthy relationship to one's own
Death Becomes a condition for
a properly celebratory
way of living now yeah and without death
and the idea that somehow your life
could just stretch on and on it would
cease to be a joyous thing at all of
course yeah but what you're talking now
is a kind of like
you know nice he almost humanist logical
way of thinking about death the creation
of God comes from a much much deeper
psychological soup that is nothing to do
with well obviously and I agree with you
obviously life would start to become
exhausting and meaningless and it's
weird if you just live forever it
wouldn't it wouldn't work that doesn't
mean you don't want it yeah because
wants and desires come from a much more
complex unsayable not logical place then
worked out in your head like oh yeah
that wouldn't actually be very nice to
live forever of course it wouldn't yes
the only thing though is that well
you've written a book yeah which is
logical and worked out and and put in
those terms
um but about uh psychology so it's not
necessarily the case or from a
psychological sense of why I might
desire this so they're perhaps not in
opposition the idea of something that
has worked out and rational and desirous
yes I don't actually completely agree
with that there's a bit in the book
where I talk about uh how God is also
like it's not just about death I think
God is also and I use update this update
talks about how uh he also it's a bit
about sleep as well and he imagines
humanity is kind of the child in bed uh
being comforted by the sounds downstairs
comforted by knowing that your parents
are downstairs uh and he talks about how
that sort of creates that there must be
something Beyond there must be because
there must be people watching over us
and that mustness that imperative is his
reason for why there is a God and it's
my reason for why there isn't let me
just explain something else yes
ready oh yeah well it's fantastic um but
one of the things is that I also talk
about God is not just being a way of uh
outsmarting death but also a way of
providing this parent figure and again
it's not as simple as like it's just a
caring parent you know I don't want to
get all Freudian on it but the way that
we might if we were to unconsciously
project a parent figure that is always
there for us they would also be angry
they would also be hateful they would
also be difficult we would also having
to be constantly doing things for them
that might not match up to what we
wanted because what we are in the
unconscious is a soup of anxiety and
desire but I wasn't going to call it the
god anxiety and desire because that's a
title okay well that can be the
sequel okay of course well that may
sorry that may explain because one of
the things that really interests me as
well is that
there was a theologian a 20th century
German Theologian who then moved to
America called Paul tillich and yeah he
described no I haven't except in the
writings of John Updike okay okay until
they've described three different things
that over you know it's a very broad
brush sort of meta narrative that
probably one we ought to be suspicious
of but he describes three different
points in Christian history in the 2000
years where people look to God to sort
out three different anxieties
um and death was the first one
interestingly so lots of early Christian
art
is centered on the idea of conquest of
death to triumph over death
um and and the sorts of things that are
depicted in are often
moments of Victory and it's either the
devil or or some
some sort of visualization of death as a
monster or whatever being defeated yeah
and then in the time of the Reformation
it's sin
and and uh and so what God does is sort
out not So Much Death but but the
problem of sin because people are really
worried about that yeah and then He
suggests that the the modern
big modern anxiety is meaninglessness
and you as you've as you've said in
summarizing the book in a way you deal
with the first and the third and there's
a sort of interesting hole there in the
middle about the sin one yeah you're
probably right about that and it's
interesting that I have to bring in
Frank Skinner at this point because uh I
tell this story
um I I tell this story about how when I
first met Frank
um I didn't realize how devout and how
literal a Catholic Frank was and uh we
went on a long journey on a long car
journey and he was explaining to me
something very specific which I think
I'm going to tell you uh because it's
it's in its mechanics as the mechanics
interest me so Frank at the time left
his wife
um and he was living I think he'd
actually got divorced and he was living
with his girlfriend uh and uh he was
having sex with his girlfriend now that
in the Catholic church is adultery right
and he was explaining to me that what
this meant was was that he couldn't go
to confession because to get confession
you have to confess your sin and then
promise not to do it anymore at which
point you get Absolution and then you
can take communion right and he's
explaining this to me over about an hour
and a half because I don't really
understand it and at the end of it I get
out the car at Birmingham New Street
Station and I say to him sorry why are
you bothered about all this and he said
no you don't understand I think I will
burn in hell fire because of this and I
literally had never heard anyone say
that you know I don't live in 1605 I've
never heard anyone say that and and
really mean it and I was really kind of
impressed at some level I didn't think
oh thus he's an idiot I thought that's
friendly impressive that he really
really feels that that makes him more
interesting I've only just met him I
know more interesting a person than I
thought but what it does mean in terms
of what you're saying and that's
probably true is because I come from I
guess a Jewish background and obviously
the book is quite talmudic at some level
Jews don't have much of a conception of
afterlife and the Judgment that is going
on for Jews for orthodox Jews and by the
way there are 613 mits vot which are
things you're meant to be doing all the
time as a Jew as far as I can make out
it's a kind of OCD thing where you're
what you've got to kind of wrap
something around your head or turn off a
light or not eat this bit of pork or
whatever the it is and and what
that what those people where that comes
from the anxiety and primordial soup
that comes from is anxiety about
judgment in this life and that comes and
I should have said this in the book this
is all kind of interesting I wish I put
this into my book anyway second edition
that comes from being a persecuted
minority that comes from the sense that
people are going to do bad things to you
all the time and you can't really do
anything about it but maybe if you do
all these weird things all the time they
will shield you from it but what I don't
have I think is a sense which you've
sort of mentioned of the idea of
judgment in the life to come and so
maybe that is why I've missed that out
because I guess
yes if you are really frightened in a
genuine way of judgment in the Life to
Come Oblivion may seem preferable I
don't think it really makes much
difference to my sense that God is still
a creation of desire and anxiety it's
just another type of anxiety I suppose
the question part of the question is
whether that is as primordial a part of
all human experience as as the fear of
death is and
um or whether part of what you know
you've characterized as some of the
differences between Judaism and
Christianity might suggest that there
are more
sort of historically inflected
circumstances in which some kinds of
anxiety Dominate and I guess that's
tillic's point
um so it might not be as universal
you know there might be more sort of
more more variety in the historical
contexts and the and the cultural and
religious contexts in which people need
God for different things
so you know there may be a there may be
something that's less primordial in
other words maybe it's interesting to
talk about I guess desire and what I
guess what we mean by desire what you
mean by desire
how I guess you've alluded to the idea
that it's perhaps not entirely conscious
to what degree do you choose what you
desire as Updike I think said I chose to
believe in God yes that he he made that
consciously and CSUS would say if your
rationality Gets In Your Way gets in the
way of your faith then don't have it as
it has to involve your rationality but
so I guess my question is
how do you know what you're Desiring is
it by seeing what your life is like and
go
oh I can back
sort of reverse engineer from what it
seems to be I'm projecting how can you
tell what your desires are I suppose
yeah
that's a really good question I think
because I think in the book I am retro
engineering I am looking at what I think
God does uh in terms of what what he
serves in the human psyche and I'm retro
engineering and saying okay well these
are things that I feel which is I am
friend of death I am frightened of
meaninglessness uh I sort of wish there
was a more universal justice and I also
beyond that and that's more
psychoanalytical have a sense that yeah
there's all these anxieties and unknown
things so desire as a if one is to be
Freudian about it desire would always be
something that you might not be able to
completely name and identify so I am
assuming in writing about the God desire
that some of those desires might be at
the Forefront of your head and some of
them will be almost unnamable and that
is partly why I think the imagination of
God isn't just a straightforward thing
and it certainly isn't just
straightforwardly a good nice thing
right I think
um because I think we're trying to play
out all sorts of things that might come
under the headline of Desire but I I
wouldn't be able to say you can name all
of them yeah and yes what was your
response to the question of desire
within the book and and is there a
specific kind of desire for God that is
different
from other desires
I think there is yeah well okay so the
the one of the classic statements about
desire is Central Augustine the the
fourth and early fifth century Bishop in
North Africa
um who who says in the in his
confessions our hearts are restless till
they find their rest in you he's talking
to God most of the book is a lot of
extended address just a desire he also
says God make me celibate but not yet
yeah there's that great one but yeah
continents you know he wants consonants
only when yeah the title is right yeah
um but the that that sense of the heart
being Restless until it Finds Its rest
is probably one of the most paradigmatic
theological statements of what desire
for God is it's the sort of ultimate
it's connected with the idea of ultimate
rest
and
um we it's quite proper from Augustine's
point of view to desire
anything that God has made so you know
the world is full of desirable things
and that's good
but the problem as Augustine sees it is
to desire them as though they are
they're going to give you that final
rest
um even those you most dearly love
um
you know they won't ultimately abide and
you and so you know there's always going
to be a sense of loss and so insane the
way he's dealing with some of the same
anxieties that you describe of losing
your parents and losing your best friend
um and he go he describes these
experiences of bereavement in the book
um so for him the key thing about the
desire for God is that it's the God is
the only object
that doesn't let you down in the end and
the way to love things in the world is
to love them as as if you like
oh a part of your love for God as a way
of loving God rather than as if they
were God so I guess that would be that's
like hiding behind Augustine that that
would be part of an answer that I feel
has some interest well you brought up
something which I think is important
which slightly takes us back to what
we're talking about earlier which is to
talk about being very frightened of
death can make you feel in a way very
narcissistic I sort of deal with this in
the book about how uh early on in my
life I read about the idea that it was
very narcissistic to be very frightened
of your own Extinction and then actually
again I know we've mentioned him a lot
but Updike in self-consciousness which I
think you've got there that's under
there this is um pigeon feathers okay
self-consciousness he talks about how uh
it's the opposite that what you want if
you want you're not to die is you want
to be part of the social being you don't
you want to stay in the party you want
to be with people and of course as I've
grown older one thing that's become
clear to me as well is that if you want
to talk about the front of your head and
desires that you know about other people
you love die never mind you and your own
Oblivion other people you deeply love
die and the real and actually early on
in the book when I'm talking about me as
a six-year-old I'm praying I'm praying
to Hashem which is the Jewish the Hebrew
word for God and I'm praying that I
should see my mum and dad and my best
friend Saul Rosenberg again after I die
because it is about being amongst people
amongst love and about about the
immediacy of you know friends and
relatives or whatever so I think that's
important in terms of like understanding
what I'm talking about the Cod desire it
isn't just like my own Oblivion that I'm
talking about here well the end of
pigeon feathers could be written for you
and when he's describing at the end
holding these two pigeons and um
he he says in the in the book The
slipping sensation along his nerves that
seem to give the air hands he was robed
in this certainty that The God Who had
lavished such craft upon these worthless
Birds would not destroy his whole
creation by refusing to let David live
forever right well that that's
so just to be clear if people don't know
so that short story by John Updike is
about a a guy who has a crisis of faith
and then sees a pigeon feather and is
moved by the intricacy of the pigeon
feather to confirm his sense that God
must exist because why would so much as
you say so much incredible apparent
energy and thought and physically Beauty
and beauty and Beauty absolutely go into
something and that's where we get into
an interesting thing which is so in this
book I don't spend much time I talk
about it a bit but I sort of like it's
been about time dismissing certain
arguments like I'm not going to bother
with that so I'm not going to bother to
get into arguments about what existed
before the Big Bang Yes or is there some
kind of designer to the or whatever
because I kind of think those things are
basically unknowable no and what seems
very interesting about the book
um is you talking about what you want
and your and what's so interesting about
it is
it's as much a question to you and and
what you feel your desires are and and
what could possibly answer it